antoine bonjour alors que symbolise
c'était le feu est bien pour les
belligérants mais avant tout pour la
population de l'est de l'ukraine cela
représente l'espoir l'espoir d'un répit
l'espoir que cesse enfin les hostilités
en effet les deux présidents se sont
ennuyés au téléphone principalement afin
de faire le point sur la situation dans
le donbass
ils se sont félicités de ce
cessez-le-feu le site complet et global
à l'ensemble de la région qui fait
partie du plan de route des accords de
minsk signé en 2015 une trêve dont on
d'ores et déjà pris acte les parties
prenantes au conflit écouter en vertu
des accords négociés par le groupe de
contact tripartite à minsk le 22 juillet
2020 nous procédons à un cessez-le-feu
complet et indéfinie l'ensemble du
personnel de la milice populaire à
l'interdiction d'utiliser des armes
quelles qu'elles soient y compris de
petits calibres à partir du 27 juillet
2020 à 00h01
sur instruction du chef de la république
populaire de deux nièces qu le
département de la milice populaire a
émis un ordre pertinents qui était
dûment soumis pour la signature à toutes
les unités et à chaque soldat
concrètement ce cessez-le-feu a été
obtenue à la suite d'une réunion du
groupe de contact la semaine dernière et
qui a convenu de mesures supplémentaires
pour contrôler le respect de la trêve
reste à espérer que ces mesures
supplémentaires suffisent comme toutes
les précédentes tentatives de cessez le
feu n'ont hélas pas duré bien longtemps
de son côté volodymyr elin ce qui a
particulièrement insisté sur la
nécessité de poursuivre la libération
d'un ressortissant ukrainien je cite
détenus dans le donbass en crimée et en
russie d'ailleurs poutine s'est pour sa
part dit préoccupé par une loi récemment
adoptée par le parlement ukrainien qui
ouvre la voie à des élections régionales
en 2022
ce qui est d'après lui contraire aux
accords de minsk et met en danger les
perspectives de règlement du conflit
les deux présidents finalement se sont
entendus pour dire qu'il était
prioritaire de mettre en oeuvre les
résolutions prises à paris lors du
sommet au format normandie 2 décembre
dernier beaucoup de bonnes intentions
donc à voir maintenant comment la
situation va évoluer sur le terrain
merci antoine pour toutes ces précisions